yep don't know
uh
[Music]
so what now what now
he's a pro boxer
[Music]
but then his agent tells us
very good
maybe
but maybe that's better if razer's
winning anyway
maybe you're looking at yourself
hey you don't even know
okay
i came to see the fight of the year
everybody on the streets buzzing about
it
don't let me down
gonna take you to kiss my feet beg for
[Music]
mercy
[Music]
i'm ready good
ladies and gentlemen nice
citizens it's time for our heavy weight
to vote
each other tonight just like we have
right
oh
ladies and gentlemen
right
[Music]
my videos
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no one's
appreciate the pep talk
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
let's start this thing
[Music]
it is good
got him staggered just gotta land a few
more
oh
like that
[Music]
[Music]
okay
what
you think this is how it ends
did i just let you out my grip you'd be
wise too
don't think you could take another
beating
say no between us meet again
next year definitely ain't glass
let's see around there i suggest you
train in the meantime
no time